[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone you are watching another
gamespot
charity stream for play for all um i am
tamar hussein and i am
joined today by a very illustrious guest
you may know him as youtube's uh i super
eye patch wolf
i know it's a pleasure to be here thank
you so much for joining us
um yeah this is one of the many benefits
of
um play for all is we've been able to
reach out to a bunch of people
um across the industry um and kind of
just collaborate with them
and it's been a kind of like a dream
project for a lot of us because it means
that we've got a good excuse to reach
out to people we're fans of and just be
like
hey do you want to do this with us and
you are
one of the people that i'm a huge fan of
i know that there's a
rather large gamespot contingent that
loves your videos and watches them
um so this is amazing
for people who don't know yeah it was
honestly like it was weird for me as
well because like i've been going a game
spot
since like you know the internet was a
thing in dublin and it was like
what a game spot oh okay
it was it was really cool i remember
sending you the email and i was very
gingerly sending the email i was like
he's not gonna he's not gonna
do anything with us he's like way too
good for us
and then you were like yeah my friend's
like i remember speaking to lucy and
chastity who
organized it with us and i was like he
actually said yes and then i told like
ben and jean-luc and they were like
what so yeah for people who don't know
super eye patch wolf um i don't want to
pigeonhole you as an anime
person but like it's okay i made i made
my bed
yeah that's that's certainly where i
kind of my entry point right you you are
to to be reductive a youtube essay is
the almost
um but like started with anime but not
just like standard anime really
insightful
smart um essays and kind of elect
analytical studies of anime and the
industry itself
but you've branched out into just pop
culture as a whole kind of you've done
one of your best videos is is one on the
simpsons and the downfall of that and
it's amazing so if you haven't seen
super patchwolf's youtube videos essays
go to his channel and subscribe
because i can tell you for sure it is
some of the best on the internet i
adore it so please check it out
that's very sweet thank you but today
we're going to be playing what remains
of edith finch
um before we get into it um i do want to
point out that we're doing this
in aid of raising money for two very
important valuable courses the first one
being direct relief
we're raising money in partnership with
the um organization
for covid relief efforts
and you can see the links on the screen
for both of these charities
uh bit.ly4gs hyphen um
kovid is for covet relief and then the
other one is black lives matter
um incredibly important cause and that
is bit.ly
forcefgs hyphen blm if you donate the
money goes directly to those causes
gamespot does not get in the way of it
we're just helping raise the money and
awareness around it
um yeah so please donate generously if
you can if you can't please share the
link and raise awareness around it
and without further ado let's get into
some edith finch
um so before we start tomorrow i
actually did a little research on this
game and i thought i'd just drop
drop a couple of little facts about it
just some interesting kind of tidbits
um so this is a first person shooter and
it's the sequel to 2016's doom
and um i'm just gonna read the back of
the box here
hell's armies have invaded earth become
the
become the slayer and i'm guessing the
slayer is this edith finch character
yeah
yeah in this epic single-player campaign
to conquer demons across dimensions and
stop the final destruction of humanity
the only thing they fear is you so i'm
guessing that like we're in for a lot of
high octane action
a lot of a lot of demon killing a lot of
rocket launchers
just kind of some real visceral violence
action-filled stuff yeah so i'm looking
forward to it
as a gamer if you don't already have
carpal tunnel you will definitely have
carpal tunnel you might even walk away
with some rsi that's the kind of game
i'm excited honestly that's kind of
that's that's what i wanted
so break your body for gaming that's
what we're all about here
yeah so without any further ado let's
just let the carnage begin okay
yeah rip and tear rip and tear let's go
okay so straight away i'm kind of
surprised at the setting
this maybe is a yeah it's a little slow
oh flowers oh yeah oh i mean okay
almost certainly poisonous flowers yeah
or maybe demon flowers even we don't
know
uh let's see a lot of this isn't going
to make sense to you
it already doesn't no not no
i'm so lost already
okay i'm guessing that broken arm is
from punching a demon in half
right in the face cacao demon right in
the gob
uh zaki chen in the uh super petrol uh
chat says we've got a comedian here
ladies and gentlemen
i am keeping an eye on both the games
for um youtube chat and the super ipad
12 chat
so anything any questions you have
let us know so
tomorrow i know nothing about this game
i have never played it before i
i don't know what the deal is
maybe she thought i'd know it's
so when we were talking about this game
like playing this game
i kind of i wasn't like i wanted to give
you an
out in case you wanted to take it just
because this is one of those games that
i think is really really special
and it's also one of those games that
like the experience
of it can be quite profound um yeah i've
heard that before
all right yeah but my
my thinking was like i'm just going to
make sure he knows that if he wants to
play this
in isolation off a stream he has that
available to him
because i don't i didn't want there be a
situation to be like damn that was
amazing i wish i wasn't
being screamed out by another person and
on a stream at the same time
but you kind of like these kind of
experiences right
uh yeah one of my favorite one of my
favorite experience stream was actually
streaming um
devotion which was the the really great
horror game from red candle studios uh
taiwanese horror game
very really interesting
intimate experience and
kind of like touched on a lot of like
you know pretty profound stuff but like
the idea of experiencing that for the
first time
with people was actually awesome and so
i am very down for whatever we have here
yeah i think this is i mean technically
you would call this
in in the uh trumped up genre label
uh a walking simulator sure
you know i find that to be quite
reductive
yeah totally i think there's definitely
like a better name for that stuff
but um an experiential narrative game
there we go
made that [ __ ] up and it's whack
looking in i felt like the house itself
had been waiting for me
i love the stuff like this that's re
like even just like the positioning of
the text is super cool
oh nope let's take that down
okay um
tomorrow i'm very bad at games and
especially on stream
so i might need your guiding hand at
certain points if i fail to make any
significant progress
i'm trying to remember how much i i can
i have i do like this game a lot but i
don't remember it being particularly
difficult i think it's one of those
games where it's just like you just have
to poke around for a bit and eventually
you'll know
it'll become obvious what you can do
plus we have plenty of people watching
in chat that can help us out
excellent if need be but
see it's just stuff like this like when
you reach a dead end it usually means
that
it's just a different part
god like it's a simple looking game but
it's beautiful
it is yeah and i think
you said you don't know much about it
right nothing
okay so i think it's one of those games
that kind of like plays on the
family the expectation that is around
walking simulators
but they seem to be quite muted and
quite grounded
it starts to have fun with that hair and
there
okay that's cool like how after lewis
started working at the cannery we all
got
sick of eating salmon except our cat
molly
interesting alara katunda in the super
eye patchwolf chat says there's like
one puzzle which is pretty
pretty accurate i'm actually really glad
to hear that because
i get the worst like let's play text
with simple puzzles my brain just like
stops working
you know yeah that's one of the reasons
yeah i try and
i don't stream much because that
performance anxiety can just make you
fireplace had a story do weird things
the bricks came from the original house
after it sank
the table was still a wreck from the
night we left
it was like a bomb had gone off killing
everyone but sparing the furniture
seems like everyone left in a hurry
yeah um
you were talking about uh i guess like
the analytical quality of a lot of my
videos
and i'm gonna say that um
use it using that ability right now
something's not quite normal here
now this is why you get paid the big
bucks baby yeah it's
it's all in you know the details you
just you look out for stuff
um oh man oh wow that's so cool
god the interior this place is looks
deadly
my mom yeah that's the optimist but she
never stopped believing that my brother
milton was alive
there's like a madcap quality too to
everything in this
game i have been in houses not
dissimilar to this
um they're
i always get like [ __ ] which short
stories should i tell on stream
but um there was one time when i
was out and i'm a very nice person
and they were really super cool and
super fun and they invited me back to
their house
and when i got back to their house it
looked kind of like this
but there were books everywhere and i
swear to god about 40 cats
running in between those piles of books
and it was one of the strangest houses i
ever saw this this sounds like an
amazing house i love books i love cats
uh the smell of piss kind of detracted
from the charm a little bit i would say
but it was definitely a memorable
experience
like i've still never seen an interior
like that again
oh whoa that's a door that is a a choice
a choice was made here
so a couple people in chat are saying um
they want a super chat don't worry about
super chat stuff
i'm keeping an eye on things and i will
read out comments
uh wherever possible if you want to
donate you can see the two links on the
screen
um bit.ly forceless js hyphen blm or gs
hyphen kovid
those are the important courses we want
to raise money for
a bad underscore proof of concept says
uh the little details in this game
really add to it
oh wow okay this really reminds me what
was that old jurassic park game
oh was it called trespasser
and you had this weird floaty first
person hand
barbara was a child star for two years
until america grew out of it
some of this stuff is like vaguely
spooky
like i'm wondering what we're in for
here
yeah i i'm trying my best not to say
much because
even though yeah could say anything like
it would be very difficult to
encapsulate what this game is
it's just incredible i'm very intrigued
yeah okay so i got the peepholes sam
spent seven years sharing a room with
his dead brother
calvin
that sentence was calvin alive during
that time
yeah was his just his corpse just on her
bed
as a kid i just assumed every house had
peepholes and sealed rooms you weren't
allowed inside of
that's a cool bathroom wow i like that
i'd be down for a bathroom like that
okay what else we got
see i have seen like the very odd clip
of this game
but what i've seen is so weird
seems so weirdly out of context that i'm
like is that the same game
molly always seemed like a girl i could
imagine being friends with
if she hadn't died in 1947
wow okay
that would put a would throw a spanner
in the old friendship though right
that feeling of when you watch something
you're like it's just the same game
that's something very much they go for
in this
i spent a lot of time playing in great
uncle walter's room
i love these interiors dude they're so
well done regretted not sealing it up
lewis told me there were secret passages
but i never believed him
it's got uh it's got a very adams family
vibe to this
like if you know yeah yeah it's old
everyone's kind of weird in a different
way
that's cool
from the paintings on the wall it was
clear my brother milton had been here
before me
reading this maybe it sounds like i had
a plan
but i had no idea what was behind that
door
just like i had no idea where all this
was gonna lead
i'm like slowly things are coming back
to me about where this goes and i'm like
just so excited i'm like looking at this
i really hope we get through all of this
uh hopefully hopefully i'll try not to
take too long and stuff but no man i am
okay
so some of this stuff is so cool i grew
up looking at molly's room through the
peephole
being inside for the first time i felt
like i'd stepped behind a painting
molly's durable had a tiny bedroom with
its own even tinier durable cage
um where are we going
did you get a chance to play devotion at
all i didn't
so um unfortunately they pulled it
before it
yeah yeah i literally recorded it isn't
it
as a physical release so yeah yeah but
um i caught it i just caught a receding
or thread about it and
i just said all right i'll check this
out and
um man it's just such a shame that that
game like didn't get like a wider
release
because it is it's me it's like 1947.
i don't talk over too much the story
but i wanted to tell somebody about
what's going to happen
it started when mom sent me to bed
without dinner
i woke up and i was starving so i looked
around for something to eat
oh not not that little girl
is that poop in there as well come on uh
yeah poop should die yeah
yeah i mean if this little girl didn't
make it i have to feel like there's a
certain amount of darwinism at work
there
like not to be not to be dismissive of
her
all
plight
mom can i come out now we have someone
in the game spot chat new nun rocks 26
who says i've beaten this game a bunch
of times well none rocks you are now
officially our what remains of edith
finch guide
so if we run into any perfect we'll be
we'll be consulting you
uh hello to taid uh in your chat who
says waguan guys what's happening
i kept eating and eating
oh no child
oh child i ate a lot of things that
night
ah tomorrow i don't know about this
i just keep eating the girl is hungry
okay
okay then i heard chirping outside my
window
oh no it was a barn swallow going back
to her nest
swallowed the swallow
and suddenly
what
tomorrow i don't want to get too spicy
but i think this girl's a [ __ ] liar
[Laughter]
like all children
um where are we going
so we're on our branch okay
you're a cat baby finally
dude this is cool i am enjoying this
mom and dad didn't even look at me
oh that's creepy
because you're a cat they didn't know
i really enjoy how merciful the platform
controls are in this
yeah there's like a beta version of this
that is infuriating i'm sure
yeah just like playing buying a commando
i could tell she was getting really
tired
[Music]
where am i going
does that bird up where's she gone
ah
now i was like i promised that i
wouldn't climb it anymore
all i cared about was eating that mama
bird
savage oh damn okay
and suddenly i was
oh wow okay this is cool like i
i'm flying tomorrow i'm flying it's
really it really like keeps you on your
toes with
in terms of what you're seeing and
playing and feeling
got you buddy yeah a circle of life
oh damn oh no oh what kind of
l is that
brutal this game
[Music]
so already i'm kind of like yep this is
absolutely something i'm going to replay
with michelle
it's like amazing both as a playing and
a viewing experience
it's got like ghibli vibes to it yeah i
get that all right
shark
uh tomorrow we're really going to need
like a fact check on this girl's story i
really
this this now yeah she's uh
she's been in a young tiny liar
oh my god so this is the bit i saw where
i was like
no it's not the same game
i'm glad that like we're already here
how is the shark's life oh there we go
it's really cool how the controls kind
of change for each animal
exactly yeah
oh damn there we go
running and gunning says in the eyepatch
wolf chat man this got similar dlc looks
weird
it does kind of have that vibe
um guy in the gamespot chat says ipad
wolf is my favorite
so i feel like we were kind of guided to
this
to this section of the game but like is
it more open than that like could we
have gone to a different
place no it's fairly linear
okay cool in terms of how you experience
yeah because you are going through a
series of stories
when i opened my eyes everything had
changed
ah
oh that's such a cool control method
so basically i'm controlling the
tentacle it was and then i click
and then i go up to like the farthest
point of the tentacle that's so cool
while uh let's just let this while john
has been a tentacle i just want to
remind folks that you can donate to our
courses below
um ly forward slash either gs hyphen blm
or gskovid
um and we'll uh be supporting some
incredibly valuable causes please do
donate generously
oh
huge shout out to noah isaac bell who
donated ten dollars noise has been
in almost every charity stream and
always donating thank you so much for
your kindness
thank you so much man that's so cool
really appreciate it
oh man oh oh no
so this is actually a remake of return
of the albert den so uh surprise
[Music]
i've never played return of the oberdin
either and i really really want to
oh you'd like it i think i i struggled
with it seems
super cool it's very cool but also it's
set on a ship
for most of it and it has a gentle sway
which makes me motion sick
oh no really yeah um there's a
ps4 horror game called white day it's a
korean horror game
and i really wanted to play it for a
long time
but then when i did it had the most
aggressive sway and no way to turn it
off
and it literally meant i just could not
play the game
it's yeah i i really struggle with games
that do that
okay last of us two has had it but it
luckily it's got
such good accessibility options that
lets you tweak it
there's something about the last of us
too where i still get it a little bit
even with everything turned off and i
wonder is it like the motion of ellie's
backpack or something
yeah there's something on her yeah a
focal point that you're not zeroing in
on yet
and the good smell went into an old pipe
one of the things i'm kind of shocked
about is how good all the separate
control schemes feel
like it never feels janky it always
feels kind of nice
even if this is like really [ __ ]
gross
oh no no no no
this reminds me i think it's the movie
anaconda this is an irrational affair
i've always had since watching anaconda
there's a scene where someone dies
because was it anaconda no it was like a
it was a do you remember the i don't
know if if
i don't know if you had this when you
were younger but there was an old tv
show in the uk called 999
which would basically replay it was like
recreations of stories that were
horrifying remember that
yeah i know i do remember that an
ambulance like
you know it would be like telling you
awful stories that happened to people
one of them was like
there was a story about this place i
don't think it was in england it was
somewhere where a
snake a very large snake had got into
like the toilet pipes
and while someone was sitting on the
toilet the snake came out of the toilet
and bit this person on the ass
oh i remember hearing that as a kid and
just
being irrationally scared of snake
toilets
so it's one of those things that sounds
like one of those things that just it
burrows your way
into your little child mind and there's
no getting it out
there's no i remember that show i always
remember they
they did this recreation of um
wow they did this recreation of one man
like breaking a bottle open and stabbing
another man in the face
yeah and i was like i was like four
and i was so traumatized yeah i think
nine nine nine
the t the show it's still got one of the
most terrifying
opening title sequence for music like
it's
every time i hear it gives me chills i'm
like oh don't don't play that it's like
upsetting on many different levels
tomorrow i'm not sure i like oh
damn okay
there we go i'm not sure if i believed
all of that
but i'm sure edie would have
oh old molly didn't
okay well you know i don't want to get
too down too quickly
maybe things work out better for every
other member of the family
i i i think the optimism is good you
should keep it yeah
yep totally yeah i'm a positive positive
pete
i can't describe it but i felt like some
part of molly was still here
okay what are we doing
donation for black lives matter from eli
bergmast
of 250 dollars holy [ __ ] eli thank you
so much that is
that is so cool thank you thank you so
much
eli
that's that's huge that's a lot of time
in great grandma edie's room
that's going to be super valuable to a
lot of people um
you can help massively thank you eli
for 500 years the finches have been
famous throughout norway for their
fortune
and misfortune
odin finch buries the latest victory
this is so cool
his wife ingeborg and their newborn son
johann
on january 7th 1937 he set sail with his
family
and his house hoping to leave the curse
behind
but 40 waves off the coast of washington
send the house and odin
to the bottom of the sea odin's daughter
edie
with husband sven and baby molly step
ashore on their new home
orcas island odin finch is the first to
be buried in the new family cemetery
his daughter edie's already dreaming of
a new finch house
oh no
even like the way you pull put that down
you like pull
back from it like you have to hold back
uh while there's a slight lull i'm just
gonna shout out two more donations
six dollars from connor who says thanks
to john for guessing on this much love
to you
and the lfab crew that's the let's fight
a boss my video game podcast
i'm sure that's super appreciative of
that thank you so much connor
and we have a donation for what looks
like rng
world and it's r n g w r
l d n g and r i don't know how you
pronounce that
but it's 250 towards covid relief
and this person says sorry i missed the
start of this this is one of my favorite
games of all time
thank you so much another huge that's
incredible
what was that person's name rng
world and gnr
rng thank you so much thank you so much
that's really appreciated
let's go with rng
i said thank you okay so so it's more
unfortunately old odin didn't make it
either
sad time um
yeah but like we still have a lot of
people on
this list who i'm sure fair i i think
what they do with stories like this
is they get all the sad [ __ ] out of the
way first and that way
we can kind of bask in the in the joy
later on
my mother hey it's the bathroom you love
grandpa
you still won this was the big bathroom
you want that shaggy copy i know
you know there was some perspective
things going on
when i looked in here first uh now i'm
still feeling the color i'm still
feeling the general vibe
but um it's feeling a little more silent
hill for the room
uh now that i'm actually in here and i'm
not sure i'm super down for
it uh not sure about this tub i call
these murder tubs because they just feel
like
areas to die in i love that chair in
there for
the elderly yeah
okay so that donation was from some uh
from ringworld
engineer ringworld engineer thank you so
much
thank you so much and he's he's one of
your community members so
oh thank you so much man he's hanging
out in the super fat wolf
chat thank you so much
it's in the last place you would look it
isn't in the cupboard
oh my god dude yeah like
every part of the game so far is so
weirdly thought out you know
yeah like such a meticulously crafted
experience
yeah like the coolest [ __ ] per minute is
so high
actually i want to just have a little
what do we got in here
calvin finch
okay it's more my money's on old calvin
to make it out of this alive
no problem yeah i'm glad he's a survivor
you know he's a fighter
he he's a he takes a lot of photos he
observes his surroundings very careful
mm-hmm good self-awareness we'll see
any danger coming 100 percent that he
can get
he's forts yes he builds a for look at
this bridge thing that's a
that's a like space it's unknowns that's
a just natural survivor right here
try and kill this guy
a day yeah
i knew grandpa sam had a twin and that
he never talked about him
i guess my grandpa didn't like history
any more than my mom did
calvin uh
how i want to remember my brother by sam
finch
the thing i remember is that when he
made up his mind
that was it
this is cool
buddy how you feel about swings
i don't know about this calvin wants to
fly he likes space
i told him going around was impossible
if i hadn't said that
tomorrow i don't like this calvin's
loving it
this is calvin's will he wants okay
yeah yeah no he's a born survivor he can
do this i believe in him
yeah that's all right it's just fun this
is just two kids having a good time
primary fire who are we as adults to
tell them what is safe and what is not
primary fire says i don't think there's
anything wrong with this i agree
oh god oh my god yeah this is
even watching this is giving me oh
well there is
that was a little disappointing i must
say yeah i really believed in all calvin
but i'm glad we have the rest of the
family to
fall back on really finches oh
um after the funeral edie roped off
calvin's half of the room
oh wow that's so sad and so cool
grandpa sam enlisted at 18 and never set
foot in the room again
so there's just like this complete
dividing line between these two rooms
this kid loved war this could
[ __ ] hell dude this game yeah
oh yeah it's an hour
uh big shout out to oni dino who
dominated ten dollars for black lives
matter and then ten dollars for
uh kobe references made the queen cast
and the dork
prance reign supreme really though thank
you for doing this stream everyone
only only dino is a mod in the let's
fight a boss discord
and um thank you so much for the
donation noni
i didn't understand the rest of that
it's not um
just not interested in getting into what
any of that means don't
don't worry about it it's fine it's fine
thank you so much
uh air taco aea asks a good question who
puts a swing by a cliff
yeah at some point i think the parents
maybe should have just
just stepped in a little bit there maybe
little calvin still be with us
they'd obviously been built smaller
hands and bellies
that's cute oh okay before we get out
here just wanna have a little look what
was back here
uh while uh trying to look around i'm
just going to shout out two more
donations one from
owen whalen 25 to black lives matter and
then jeffrey baker 25
to black lives matter thank you guys so
much owen jeffrey
couple class acts right there for sure
oh this is good wow i never thought
about how hard it must have been for her
afterwards
oh cool
child star
i'm surprised edie saved this one
this looks like one of those old like
1950s horror comics
i did a bunch of research on these
recently
i'm calling it the surprise
ending of barbara finch
uh don't think i'm gonna get my hopes up
for this one tomorrow i think uh
don't see a great outcome for all
barbara
she's a child star she'll be protected a
lot of people invested in her
that's right they'd never kill a child
again no
but in a lucky break she'd been asked to
perform her
signature scream at a local convention
for monster movie fans
it was just that boost
1960 i feel like beastiecon would have
different connotations now
getting better i think you just need the
right motivation
the biggest fan and current boyfriend
rick was about to demonstrate when
[Music]
now that was a great screen it
if someone offered you five million
dollars but that had to be your voice
for the rest of your life would you take
it
yes i'll take it
because my thinking is you could kind of
make more money off the voice then
start a creepy youtube channel like yeah
yeah but
i do this what if i tried a gang of
hoodlums in halloween tonight
police are urging residents to
that came from the basement you're right
also
i loved your delivery on that why is
this door locked
because my dad likes making puzzles in
secret passages
there's a key hidden in the music box
the secret
is to keep winding and winding
until finally the key pops out thanks
babe
i'll be back in a sec
20 minutes later rick hadn't returned
so barbara went to look for him right on
cue
she reached for the music box
and as she wound the key she listened
for rick
but the house was silent
this is cool
they can't do that oh they can and they
did
she found imagine the worst
that's just the hollow like it's not
like the halloween song that is the
halloween song
listen they paid they paid up i think
i think yeah okay
that was probably the most expensive
part of the development
now in fairness i have actually used
that song before but i just stole it
dude this is so cool
um
[Laughter]
oh no no other way we can go eh okay
towards the fridge it is then what could
be inside
oh dear
[Music]
i was just trying to scare you to help
you find your scream
well i'm not scared i don't know about
this rick character personally
all i'm getting from you now is that
you're hurt and confused
brick has huge douche energy yep
yep not a fan not a fan i think barbara
can do a lot better personally
and she was still holding it when she
fell asleep
watching the late late picture show
hours later barbara
walter what's going on up there ah
okay i'm coming up but if this is a
trick
you're dead walter
hmm you know rick is cool because he has
he wears sunglasses inside yeah that it
like i can argue with that as much as i
want to
that is a very cool thing to do okay
uh so tomorrow everything's fine
um some of the people who watch my
streams will know this but i don't
really get scared so like these kind of
sections are kind of just lost on me
but um let's just see
okay that's fine that's just a creaking
door
goodbye patchwolf is known for his
braveness so
yeah it's a famed brave youtuber
you've got a crutch you're fine
okay barbara there's gotta be another
way out of here
she played her part beautifully
cookies
okay
[Music]
yeah yeah barbara lives
barbara victory
not be over yet
okay well typically in horror films when
the killer goes down for the first time
that's usually it so we're saying yes
the end most horror films only last
about half an hour anyway so
yeah yeah um it's really weird but
that's that's how it is
wes craven don't know how he's managed
to make a career out of half an hour
movies
ridiculous yeah absolutely glorified tv
shows i call him
great oh dear oh what happened here
uh okay
add to that skeleton
no
[Music]
tomorrow i feel like a fool
don't you barbara lives
and she saw what kind of monsters they
were
and she realized what was about to
happen
okay wow all right
[Music]
i wasn't there myself but
i hear barbara was magnificent
poor girl she had a taste for
stardom but unfortunately
so did her fans of course the police
blamed it
all on poor rick who disappeared the
same night
and little walter hiding under his
bed the whole time they took us all
pretty hard but that's another story
as for barbara tucked inside the music
box
is all they ever found of her
her ear
now that's what i call a real ear
i like this guy yeah he's good good vibe
good vibe yeah huge fan of the crypt
keeper vibe that he's exuding
oh that's cool
maybe what edie saw was a happy ending
hey at least little walter survived what
is fine
malta is living in life somewhere um
taco a year says pumpkin man best boy
he was he was a rather good grade from
that agreed
call name guy says anime super with
eyepatch wolf
you know what that means not not a fan
generally
not a big anime guy uh why would i why
would i watch cartoons made for children
personally no
it's ridiculous yeah i like american
cartoon shows like dragon ball z
yep jojo's bizarre adventure
ah yeah the most american
yeah written by uh sam freedom
full of american patriotism it's so full
of patriotism sometimes it's a bit like
what comment downstairs platinum
yeah yeah we get it you stand
most times i played with the music box
and never found the basement key
uh we've got a 20 donation from the leg
who says great to see a stream of a fun
short story game even though it sadly
does not have that sweet sweet platinum
fine thank you so much for your donation
of twenty dollars the leg you're right
awesome the leg thank you so much
already done this bit haven't we
i guess not
we haven't done it in this time oh oh i
get you
[Music]
ah the basements thankfully the least
frightening part of any house no
basements are absolutely fine has anyone
seen it
chapter one is basements are fine
a good place you just go for a swim
sometimes are you being into horror
films tomorrow
i do yeah i do like a lot of horror
films um and i enjoy watching them it's
been a while since i've really delved
into him
yeah i used to watch him all the time as
a kid
i recently subscribed to shudder and
have been having a terrific time with
that
that's awesome yeah i need to do that i
really i love that sensation of being
scared but
as a child i was in like a top 10 s rank
coward once
oh really packages so my my family
members specifically my cousins used to
torment me by making me watch films that
i should not have been watching as a
child oh no
i did that as well yeah like six i'm
watching
texas chainsaw massacre and that kind of
stuff um
uh yeah when i was like six i watched
acura
oh i never talk about anime for a living
so that's their fault
yeah uh yeah i when i was young as they
gave me a super nintendo
to play for a bit and here i am
i remember asking mom once about where
walter had gone
um i'm gearing up to re-watch hereditary
tomorrow and i'm very excited
i think it's that none of us has gotten
very far
uh mega mega 20 able
says yo wolf didn't know you were doing
another stream today
good pleasant surprise welcome
[Music]
thank you yeah author has very been very
gracious
enough to join games for for a charity
stream so if you're watching this
we're actually playing what remains of
edith finch
for uh two causes which you can see the
links for below please donate if you can
and you guys have been running these
streams for quite a little bit now
haven't you you've done a lot
you're about five weeks in now i think
we've got maybe one and a bit
that's what week's going left i nearly
died after that one charity stream i
don't know how you guys do it
living for today
oh i always expect it to be dead
tomorrow
but if you wait long enough
this is so cool even a monster
on the other side of the door starts to
feel normal
almost friendly
[Music]
stop this
and then one day everything just
stop
whatever that thing was it was gone
maybe you got tired of waiting
or maybe i just got tired of being
afraid
how do you feel about peaches the
longest in 30 years
you know i like peaches i'm i'm
generally a fan
well i still can
only don't know so there's nice tongue
click there just for the hereditary fans
out there
oh i can't wait to watch that movie
somewhere
whatever killed barbara did you see
mid-summer
no i've not seen that yet molly i want
to watch
maybe this weekend actually it's good
stuff
yeah deeply unpleasant that's
yeah that's why i've been waiting for a
moment okay it feels
maybe it's irresponsible to watch deeply
unpleasant things in this current
time in the climate yeah
that's kind of the same that's what i
kind of feel like part of the last of us
too is kind of like um
you guys want to see the grimmest
version of reality possible that's like
no
we're okay wait we've got it we're fine
we're we're cool yeah it feels like
we're living the prequel to the last of
us so it feels like oh god i don't know
what's going on are you are you far into
last of us too
yeah i finished it a couple of days ago
how you feeling about it
i don't mind if i only have a year left
i'll tell you after this
okay
i'd be happy with one new day
i can already imagine the sun the last
of us part two
oh walter buddy rest in peace he got
pretty far though
yeah it's a shame he lived so much of
his life underground
and secular
so i'm guessing he knew he knew about
the curse and he was like
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna try and
wait this out
[ __ ] that's that's grim yeah
so yeah the last of us too i think it's
an exceptional
narrative and characterization thematic
experience
like one of the most like
thought-provoking games i've played in a
really really really long time
and it's like taking up residence in my
house just living rent-free in my brain
for the last few days um wow high praise
i think the big game the the pacing of
it is
not great i found it quite frustrating
i think a lot of the gameplay was very
uh bland like i i pretty much it doesn't
evolve in any meaningful way i'm i'm one
of those people who like wants games to
change
which is why i love this game so much or
at least it needs to be built in a way
that's
quite um rewarding on the loop
and i don't i didn't find it to be too
rewarding for me um and as as the game
goes on the pacing kind of clashes with
the repetitive gameplay style and i just
wanted to get more of the story and it
was like go and walk towards thing over
there
and i was like we're gonna stay spoiler
free here so no no worries for people in
the chat but
yeah i i respect it more than i enjoyed
it perhaps is the way to say it
i i i get you a hundred percent yeah
but i still think it's a fantastic i
feel like it's an essential play
like um we gave out seven out of 10
which i agree
but i'd still say it's a game that
everyone should play because it does
just amazing things with
characterization and
narrative theme story that kind of stuff
so you gave it a 7 out of 10.
maybe it'd be better have someone even
in contact yet
uh i don't believe so that's that's
something
that's a question i have heard them
getting in contact with
uh less than stellar reviews of that
game uh
it happens surprisingly frequently and
we've got an amazing reviews editor
um who just like i i've worked in
reviews as well and
our job is to just kind of like deflect
it as much as possible
it happens relatively i won't say it's
all the time but it's not as
uncommon as most people think um
the trick is to just be professional
oftentimes it's a lot of pr people who
are just like
people they understand that it's weird
but they're asked
to do it yeah yeah i mean
i get that yeah um
i think i think it was a 7 out of 10
anyway but um i'll double check
but if you read the review uh it's
written by um
uh callie plaguey who's our um reviews
editor it's just a fantastic review
there's two versions of a spoiler-free
review and there's a
fully in-depth review
i should give it an eight my bed um but
yeah
just a great review and i agree with it
wholeheartedly
but yeah great game despite things
i think we've been surrounded by death
for so long we've just gotten used to it
what kind of family finishes building a
cemetery before starting the house
that's such a good line
it's embarrassing for me to admit this
but
the pet cemetery may be more
uncomfortable than the human one
there are so many parallels between this
and devotion it's
it's kind of crazy
that's interesting but it was edie who
designed the cemetery
pet cemetery not a good remake you know
i i liked it
i actually liked it already i'm one of
the only people i know who had a good
time
with that movie but i thought i liked i
appreciated the changes they made
um there was one moment in it that i
really liked
and it was when you know people know
that
i won't get too spoilery or anything but
people know the general story of pet
cemetery
but there's a bit where someone gets
their kid back and it's not
quite the same
and he's like stroking the hair of his
kid and he just feels all these little
staples in her hair
oh yeah that bit i thought was like
weird and uncanny and uncomfortable and
i
really liked that yeah there's some very
good tension in that movie
like moments edie said she dreamed about
the old house
i think it's less scary than the
original but i think the original is
absolutely horrifying
yeah the old house oh no way
so that's the house that sank
edie's side was always easier for me to
understand
but the older i get the more i can see
where my mom was coming from
she lost two of her brothers just like i
did i get why she tried so hard to
protect
us
just to watch this as she tried punching
the curse
that would do it curses and ghosts are
notoriously vulnerable to physical
physical attack behind everything
watching crime is the ladder i'm just
going to remind folks to please donate
if you can
um towards black lives matter and
covered relief efforts both links are on
the screen bit.ly and either
forward slash uh gs hyphen blm or force
gs high from covington
and we might even read out your
beautiful name you never know
any anything could happen anything
that's the least we could probably do
but will we do it
ah don't need to find out sonny yeah
only one way to find out right
at tomorrow there was a moment uh when i
was talking to you earlier and i was
like
what what charities are we collecting
for
because i realized i hadn't asked and i
was terrified the answer was going to be
like oh building the wall and i was like
oh
okay well you're committed now so
you're on team wall i have to
um yeah they're really great causes and
like um you know i'm
happy to be part of this even just a
little bit to help support cool stuff
like that
uh for sure um we are if folks don't
know
we're partnering with direct relief
which is helping out healthcare workers
on the front lines helping people who
have colvid
and black lives matter which obviously
is
campaigning to end systemic racism
against black people in
various communities both in america and
around the world so please donate
generously if you can just being in
front of the camera
i guess we're all afraid of something
[Music]
instead of hiding from death sam seemed
to go out of his way to meet it
daniel moreno um great guy from our
community says i appreciate her time
where it gives impressions the last i
was part two in order for ipad 12 to
experience walter's death
[Laughter]
that was uh that was a moment of pro
streaming i call that yeah
you knew exactly when to drop the
information when to pull back
it was good don't want to get in the way
of death
so it hasn't come up too much on this
play on on this game because it's so
kind of linear i have such an awful
sense of direction and i always worry it
makes my streams miserable
because i'll like circle around the same
room so many times
before actually finding where i'm meant
to be see i do that
same thing but when i'm streaming if i
ever do that on a stream i just act like
i'm
paying really close attention to the
details in the environment
oh that seems such a good idea yeah i'm
really appreciative oh that's happening
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
ban all my current stream audience
and just start fresh so i can pretend to
do that
yes no one can ever say that you didn't
have that skill if there's no everyone's
banned
yeah reptiles rolls says
he's a huge fan of yours and wants to
shout out shout out to reptiles raw
rept what was his name reptiles roll
reptiles rule thank you so much dude
appreciate you watching the videos
it's getting spooky again it's getting a
little spooky
someone asked if you had a note on the
desk
no i don't think i did let's head back
there real quick
let's have a quick look just in case
someone said when you're talking about
potentially being set up with what
charity
just watch says no you misunderstand
these are donations for the virus
to make it more dangerous and oh not
again
oh god no of course
we are working to stop or mitigate the
impact of the viruses
good shout by uh who was that
um in making sure that we read the note
i promise oh my god i can't believe you
could miss this
[Music]
it's a hunting trip don shooting is
strongly encouraged
oh
oh damn what happened there
oh the game crashed let me forget that
yeah it just got straights crashed there
i'm taking that gratitude back i can't
believe you absolutely set us up for
making us
interact with a bug there yeah
i'm on a charity stream dude come on
come on dude ridiculous
um i will i guess will i try that again
or do we not want to risk the crash
again try again
if it someone said oh mega 20 able says
did it doki doki or is it a legit crash
it was a legit crap
oh i'm up for that becoming like popular
verbage yeah
let's try this again if it crashes again
then we have to skip it
sam that's my impression of dean from
supernatural favorite one oh man you
should hang out with michelle
big supernatural fan oh snatcher is so
underrated
you know she's shown me episodes from it
and like they're legit good
yeah and like it's it has fun with
itself
like there's like the ones where like
they enter like an alternate dimension
and it's a fan convention
for them yes there's one where they end
up on like a japanese game show
which is like kakima tsukai or they have
just oh i remember that's games yeah
it's amazing what was the name of their
fake sitcom
oh damn it's going to annoy me i don't
remember it
it was it was real funny yeah
but yeah that show gets a bad rap and
it's actually pretty fun yeah
uh lara cathedral says the the good
episodes are good but the bad episodes
are really bad that's
pretty much yeah yeah yeah
just need to get a shot of you don then
we can hit the road
what
it's gonna rain the whole weekend isn't
it
i can't believe we nearly missed this
bit this is so cool
it's wild that they let you skip it i'm
gonna take some pictures okay
just be careful the camera is older than
you are
you're right dad it's starting to clear
up i really want to play that um
umarangi generations game have you seen
that at all
no no it's basically a gamer taking
photos
in like uh kind of
dystopian city and it looks great i
usually
um youtuber nitro rad has a really good
video about it
uh you should check check that guy check
that out but it looks really cool and
it's got like a real like
jet set radio art style huh
what's it called umarangi generations
oh i see it here
what am i missing what am i missing
let me just take some cool see if you
can take some photos of him
is he around
yeah you just have some fun take some
photos
roger takes photos let's just remind you
guys
that we are raising money for black
lives matter and corvid 19 direct relief
efforts
so please use the links below bit.ly
forward slash yes hyphen either covet or
blm
to donate i think our um
[Music]
dedicated moderator richie is in the
chat so richie if you could drop the
links into chat
that would be amazing and they're also
in the youtube
description here she also says jet set
radial style
say less seems like you've sold him
excellency i haven't played it myself
and i think it's getting a switchboard
at some time at some point
but it's out now on steam and look it
just looks really cool like
really really cool god damn it where do
i
what am i doing here i think this is it
i think you just have to take photos
for a bit
someone in chat will tell us if we're
doing the wrong thing
says this is the rest of the game enjoy
okay cool good stuff
a real strong start to old uh what
remains at universe
i'll be fine dad you know who else
thought he was going to be fine
some guy who died don i'm being serious
that is a very good serious dad
i haven't been out voice in 20 years don
don't you think you could find something
more
interesting to photograph
[Music]
i know you're having a good time here
but pisa has just announced that it's
going bankrupt
well that's tomorrow you really brought
down the tone of this stream
i believe there's something in the upper
right and far upper right and
far upper left oh what's
[Music]
what
dad damn
that girl's got a gun
do i have to do this don you don't have
to do anything
but if you want to survive you'll need
to be strong
dude teacher karate yeah you have to use
nunchucks
and keep yourself squared up i like
ninja stars
ninja star is great options yeah
you know how many people ninja stars
accidentally kill each year
none because [ __ ] ninjas using them
you think they make mistakes
no do you think anyone sees someone else
from the ninja stars and
thinks yeah i'm gonna pick this fight no
they're the ultimate deterrents yeah
exactly no one wants smoke with anyone
holding ninja stars
yeah bangkok i really believe
ninja stars
oh i'm a big fan of band oh damn okay
oh no
i'm proud of you dawn always remember
i'm proud of you dad
kill the living creature
sorry don just got to reset the timer
let's take a picture of his face
this is awful oh weird i'm here okay
oh oh you're playing him aren't you
so do i go up to her oh that that messed
with me
just trying to get a shot of the two of
us together oh so he's
that's how you set the timer and then
leg it now
ah
dad it's twitching i think it's totally
normal though
oh
you absolutely hate to see it dad
sucks you know what would i would have
helped him
wish mostly out tomorrow i'm sir 100
you think anyone ever survives a ninja
uh shuriken
no i've seen naruto and let me tell you
they do not
no every shuriken thrown in naruto lands
and kills
one hit gets gets a little boring about
400 episodes
but it's it's still you know he had a
point to make and he made it
it's basically one punch man energy on
ninja stars
[Music]
okay we're just fulfilling the uh the
promise of speaking about anime hair
with these references
laura katunda says man the shuriken in
naruto might as well be confetti
which is a great way to put it there was
a point like when i was watching um
dragon ball z and you know like someone
does a big energy blast
and smoke goes everywhere and they're
like well that's it job done let's all
and it's like
okay gohan sure thing
uh my favorite partner was when they did
the very big shurikens do you remember
those the right earlier franchise it was
like
massive ones and then they very quickly
got rid of those
what happened not enough budget for big
shurikens
uh we have a 10 donation from faye who
says this donation goes out to the
nameless one
jam and his wonderful celebrities also
black lives matter can i get a hell yeah
hell yeah yeah who's that from that's
from faye
faye thank you so much um i will
i will report your donation to the
nameless one thank you yeah
and then finlay doyle also donate ten
dollars thank you so much finley
finlay thanks a million do you remember
the way gregory used to laugh
i thought he was alone like something
funny was happening but only he could
see it
oh man yeah new mechanic
finally some some merriments tomorrow
some oh my god wholesome fun a baby in a
bathtub what could
possibly go wrong absolutely nothing
buddy
i got this frog i got this awesome duck
no death no need for anything oh god oh
uh okay tomorrow i don't like this with
this one how do we how do we click out
of this
i'm now deeply uncomfortable i believe
it's oh god
hold on sweetie look at the whale though
that whale hello oh the whale looks down
pretty great whale
whale's eyes are moving right now oh
something bad's happening outside with
mama
no tomorrow we we just we got this
beautiful frog
we got these awesome little ducks
there's nothing nothing to worry about
buddy we're fine
this is how you remake frogger yep
reminded me so
much oh whoa
[Music]
lost in his imagination
i'm like i'm liking this gregor kid uh
great imagination practically
indestructible
it's good stuff it's good
no issues
[Music]
hmm
the track slaps yeah
absolute banger 800 years later still a
banger and
yeah i'm very confident it was recorded
800 years ago
yeah okay what are we doing
[Music]
huh okay
it sure made him happy yeah yeah
yeah there we go in the party this is
fantastic
yeah look at his face he's loving it
he's just fantastic
best character of 2017 yeah
okay what else are we doing here
get on
do we gotta get on the whale maybe
ah there we go
damn that was a hell of a body fan
from the top rope
all right are you a wrestling fan
tomorrow uh
not anymore i wasn't i wasn't the
attitude
actually i might be might be doing
something with the attitude era in a
little bit
that's that sounds good
interesting time for wrestling maybe
yeah i've i've seen some
so i watch your uh what you're what
you're currently liking and i'm very
interested
by that whole john cena storyline
oh that was fantastic yeah
great video on it as well
just getting cleaner and cleaner get all
that dirt out turn out of there
uh
[Music]
okay okay this is much better than what
i thought was happening for a second
there
all good in the hood
oh there's our friends you just make the
whole game like this
just happy and nothing nothing no
problems at all
you are the frog hey
[Music]
oh
okay don't worry don't worry it's okay
love sam
ah
uh
okay well well tomorrow once again the
mood has been brought down
yeah it's a bit of a you hate us here
maybe we should have played moving out
okay it looks like there's something on
that table behind you
i can't imagine my mom ever writing
poetry yet
a poem for us who always said okay
tomorrow i i don't think i can get my
hopes to up about ghosts
at least not very hard he's just flying
a kite
there's nothing okay okay you know you
know what i'm sorry i'm sorry i
i had grown cynical this is obviously
very wholesome
exactly just flying a kite
but gus stood far apart just flew his
kite and bottled up the storm inside his
heart
that's how you deal with emotions right
just boil it up that's fine i know i do
oh yeah buddy
fly
[Music]
extremely chaotic vibes there
whoa whoa tomorrow can you censor that
on the stream
um we should be fine we'll just go okay
okay good yeah no i don't want to be
associated with that kind of behavior
personally
absolutely awful gus
disgusting yep no just
not not a fan of disrespect to your
elders not one damn [ __ ]
oh what's going on oh this is so cool
the rain came down in buckets then but
no one seemed afraid
that nature might destroy the tent our
dad had truly made
lara katunda says baby death is fine but
i draw the line that middle finger
absolutely i could not agree more yeah
death is one thing but profanity and
rude gestures
get out of here death is an
inevitability profanity is a choice
well this is this wedding has taken a
turn yeah
not not the best no oh
dear
i wish that i could truly say i thought
about you on that day
out there on the beach alone just you
the wind
the sea and foam but i didn't
until we found you
so you know it's more my decision to not
become emotionally invested
in ghosts paying dividends right now
buddy
i mean gus seemed like a bit of a a
reckless person anyway
yeah i'm not saying he deserved it
no but at the same time
[Laughter]
oh you put the middle finger up and
there
that the loft showed him brothers died
during the home stretch of this game
i've got maybe like half an hour left in
it
really so the only thing that could
spoil it
is if i'm very bad at playing it
it's fine it's fine she spent a summer
building houses in kolkata where she met
my dad
sanjay pick up sanjay
seems like he seems like a good guy nice
nice nice cool smile
religion was another thing my mom never
talked about but i think it helped her a
lot after her dad died
they got religion
[Laughter]
okay when my dad died i don't think mom
knew where else to go
i'm sure edie was happy to have her back
the house had to get a little bigger but
edie was used to that
oh and for a while
things were good almost normal but it
didn't last
[Music]
just not setting up your child for
success by calling him milton
no no no disappeared the only thing he
left behind
whatever happens after that point you
have only yourself to blame
peak okay let's see here
so tomorrow i know we like to champion
these guys and like be like oh well this
one's going to survive
but milton i don't see it just not
yeah just a gonna get killed early vibe
to him
yep huge
uh look at him try it tried his best god
help him
died with a crown on his head uh it's
the most we can any of us can ask for
oh that's nice
oh cool
actually studied animation in college
time consuming process uh i i yes
uh 100 easily all right then let's see
it
um
well tomorrow you got me
oh damn okay oh milton buddy
disappeared that's a
one way of putting it kind of reminds me
of the unfinished swan
that moment i've never played that i've
always wanted to it's really it's really
interesting
maybe you should play after playing this
yeah i totally be up for that it seems
it's it's it's been on the list for a
while
i mean
you just met milton maybe you should
play unfinished one
there's a link there
good stuff good stuff yeah i'm just
enjoying the environment
just inspecting
all the hard work that went into
developing this not lost at all
yeah that's still kind of like the
shocking things to me about this game
just how
generally dense it is like not even just
the environments but just
everything you know it's it's like
it it there's no down time there's no
like
lag or filler i guess you know what i
mean
yeah or killer no filler
literally hell yeah finally
i should make every game like this just
make it good like
it's simple when you think about it yeah
so
before we get into the next bit i'm
gonna just shout out
um our charity effort again because the
next bit is
quite good um chris lucklin gave five
dollars to black lives matter thank you
so much chris
thank you so much chris and you can
donate to if you use the links
below uh in the youtube description it's
bit.ly
forward slash gs hyphen blm or gs hyphen
kovid depending on where you want to
um donate to all the money goes directly
to those um
two efforts black lives matter and a
direct relief
so please donate generously
my hidden i think i am
i think you are okay good stuff
hard to say honestly but generally so
tomorrow
before the stream notice you're wearing
a hunter hunter t-shirt
i am that that's that's some good [ __ ]
from uniqlo oh man i'd love
uniqlo for that reason the first time i
went to japan and there was like
one-piece t-shirts i nearly lost my mind
yeah they do some good stuff with uh
sometimes they do great stuff sometimes
they do some absolutely tragic
attempts at anime licensing where it's
just like hey there's jpeg of goku or
png of goku
[Laughter]
come on guys but this is
i bought like a bunch of like one piece
and and um
uh hunter hunter stuff that was real
good
this is one of them
i think you were going right away
uh this is the wrong way apparently okay
cool
okay
let's make our way back in
so i think there's a staircase that we
missed earlier
hmm
let's go back to here yeah
next next to milton's tower
oh okay dang uh
support lesbian great yes support
lesbian
says john what's your favorite irish
food my favorite irish
food i don't like a lot of irish food
because there's a lot of it where it's
like you just
[ __ ] a bunch of [ __ ] in a pot and it's
like boil it for two hours and it's like
there we made food and it's like
and but i also like there's this kind of
like potato pancake
i think it's called like a boxy or
something like that i only found out
about it recently
and they are super good they're i found
a restaurant that did them in dublin
and i was like cool and then the
pandemic happened and i was like oh no
yeah it's outside near the tower
is that it no
like to the left of the door
um so here's
milton's
yeah so straight down and then to the
left
right but they say i think so maybe am i
going mad
i am very mad
sort of be around here
[Music]
past the classroom so i think it's that
that
set of stairs that you just saw on the
other side there
so yeah back to where you came so so
keep going around there you go
oh they're okay okay
easy to miss that one
man that sink sunken house oh my god
ringworld engineer
donated a hundred dollars and said you
missed the staircase by milton's castle
just an absolutely amazing way to
help us out there that is i think that's
the most
functional donation has ever been hey
guys there's a hundred dollars for
charity
also you missed the staircase so you're
going the wrong way shout out to
ringworld engineer thank you so much
thank you so much
um and thank you for hanging out in the
uh twitch chat for super high patchwolf
and
being a good person generally
um
[Music]
hmm uh interesting
uh noahjikball says in the games watch
hey guys it's a fan of fans of anime
what are your thoughts on
bleach well if you want to hear
super hello i wouldn't i wouldn't watch
that video
um yeah so a couple of years ago i made
a video about bleach
and kind of like it was sort of meant to
be about how i sort of fell off the
series
there's some info about in that video
that like is not
really accurate to like how shonen jump
works
and that's something i've been thinking
about a lot lately and maybe something
i'm gonna
revisit in the near future um it's a
good series
it i think it gets it falls off
like i think there's a real cut there's
a real there's
a real hard off for like prime bleach
for me
damn what am i doing here ah okay
and but like that said i do like it and
i do love the illustrations of tj kubo
the tite kubo whoever that name is
pronounced
he's like an amazing illustrator i just
i don't think he's a fantastic
storyteller
how do you feel about it tomorrow um i
will say that video still has some great
like
qualitative analysis so if you go in um
ended up watching it yeah you know
john's a cop to the fact that some of
the
data and statistics doesn't hold up but
it's still an interesting discussion
about bleach
and i think i largely agree with the
assessment of what you've said and some
of what you said in the video as well
no it started off real strong really
interesting idea for a world
and then over time just became riddled
with tropes and
its own tropes and um it wasn't really
interesting long run
yeah now it does have like its hardcore
fans and like
whenever i do a video like oh
oh god oh i'm so sorry this is good you
should
you should focus on this for a bit okay
but he withdrew himself
in our sessions i saw the same behavior
his mind began to wander
i asked him to describe it
oh tomorrow i'm i'm doing two things
this is so cool
and something moved bats
and this is really the feeling of doing
a repetitive job you don't like
by like imagining something else this is
oh man this is awesome
and things have not names
he knew it was all in his head
oh wow you took it very seriously
i had hoped he'd find himself
but he found something more
oh wow
this is really impressive yeah this is
so cool
i spoke with his boss
like a whole new lewis
so i let him go on
i even encouraged him
it seemed very promising oh this is so
cool
he told me he's made a new friend
get out of the way fishtopia
he built the city up slowly brick by
brick
then he made musicians
and songs for them to play
oh talk about starting a band and he was
always humming something
[Music]
every day his imagination grew stronger
he no longer spoke yeah this is
fantastic
but his chopping was as reliable as ever
then one day
that all the cheering crowds even the
stones under his feet
were all in his imagination
so he could do whatever he wished
oh that's so cool
he'd conquer a city then immediately
push on
you this really strikes me as one of
those sections where
it's like watching this must be so
different to playing it yeah you know
what i mean
where it's like the way it's like
dividing your attention like it does
feel like kind of daydreaming you know
yeah
i think a lot i mean the people in the
chat are like this is what like you you
hug show 420 says this is some wild
stuff
yeah i imagine some of it is coming
across quite well
even as his mother pleaded with him part
of lewis kept sailing on
uh
i don't i don't know about this dude
louis is super into it oh god damn oh
why just one okay the prince
the prince was on his own quest for
um sinister serpents
he followed the sound of his um
wait which one do you think tomorrow
which one electric guitar
said tall sorry uh tires are pretty cool
yeah they're cool
i love how it's changing
yeah hell yeah this is cool
[Music]
his chase led him to a golden palace
east of the sun and west of the moon
even then his logic remains sound
this is wow this is so crazy
get out of my
damn fish
when we started off like being the shark
rolling down the hill
i was really like well what else are
they gonna like how are they gonna top
that
this is something else yeah it's wild
[Music]
for someone who'd never known success in
the real world i think it was
overwhelming
and then it struck him that the real
lewis was not the one chopping salmon
but the one climbing the steps of a
golden palace that's so cool
my imagination was as real as my body he
told me
it's hard to argue with him
he began to forget the world we know
i think it pained him to remember lewis
the cannery worker
hmm
he began to despise the man with a royal
contempt
that's why i still thought
oh my god
incredible yeah absolutely
the wise incredible could insisted on
inviting him
[Music]
holding his crown
[Music]
there was only one thing left to do
[Music]
um
going too well for you mate gotta get
back
into the fists and the rest i think you
know
mrs vince your son was a kind man who
will be him
overworked himself lost his
sense of place died
my brother was really cool i wish you
could have met him
wow holy [ __ ] i'm kind of
i'm kind of speechless after that that
was that was incredible
you're in the home fresh now home
stretch okay let's do this
man
yeah i don't even know what to say it's
like yeah oh my god
a lot of people in the chat are also
like oh my god
she waited until the day before we left
to tell edie
i'm not sure if she wanted to make it
easier or harder
i wish we'd stayed
but i understand why we left
what happened that night had been coming
for a long time
maybe it should have come sooner
but it had to end one way or another
all that's left now is to tell you about
that last night
this is it mate
that whole last day edie just watched
his pack and didn't say a word
until supper when she raised her glass
and said
to our final night together and
all our final nights apart grandma
you know what i said about alcohol some
of your medications are very specific i
left a present for you in the hallway
why don't you go open it the grown-ups
have to
arm you now i'm sorry you're right we're
all leaving tomorrow let's just enjoy
our lives i'm not
leaving edith you're excused
that was a really cool shot
the power had been shut off that morning
but edie always had plenty of candles
when my mom said the library i don't
think she knew about the other entrance
or that edie had a key to it
god this house is amazing it's pretty
cool
like the story is very sad and it's been
harrowing but these are some [ __ ]
dope [ __ ]
love me some secret hallways
has a right to know these stories my
children are
dead because of your story
i think it's best if edith and i leave
tonight
we'll have the nursing home send a van
for you in the morning
okay
there's so many stories i wish i could
tell you
but there's only time for one this is
about what happened on the night you
were born
that night the tide went way way out
i knew we were going to this house at
some point
there'd been an earthquake out in the
middle of the ocean
they called it the lowest tide in a
thousand
years god it smelled
awful you know i've seen that house
every day of my life
oh
it's more not getting a great feeling
from this house
it's fine it's this is old and decrepit
no not right
i got turned around
around
some real last era silent hill 2 vibes
here yeah
some real ps1 era
[ __ ] i stopped
things i'd forgotten had ever existed
but when i saw them they felt like
old friends that night a lot of things
came
back to me
or maybe i came back to them
[Music]
things i can't explain but that i need
you to try and eat it
what are you doing in here it's mine
edith
mom you're gonna rip it let go
i kicked and screamed but mom dragged me
to the car
i never saw a great grandma edie again
oh man
the next morning the band came to pick
her up but she was already gone
we both tried to make the best of it
okay a few years went by
my mom didn't like to talk about it
but she started getting sick a lot
the rest happened pretty quickly
she got better for a while
and then she didn't
and then i was alone
the last finch left alive
until i found out about you
i'm still not sure what to tell you
about all this
if we lived forever maybe we'd have time
to understand things
but as it is i think the best we can do
is try to open our eyes
and appreciate how strange and brief all
of this is
this journal was supposed to be for you
but now i hope you'll never see it
i just want to meet you and tell you all
these stories myself
but i guess if you're reading this now
things didn't work out that way
this is where your story begins i'm
sorry i won't be there to see it
it's a lot to ask but i don't want you
to be sad that i'm gone
i want you to be amazed that any of us
ever had a chance to be here at all
good luck
oh man okay wow
because yeah even when we looked down
earlier i was like
that girl is a tummy that's cool that's
cool that they were like this is what a
actual person looks like but i guess
there was a little more to it than that
yeah you immediately looked down and i
wondered whether you'd twig and figure
out what was going on there
um yeah i did i didn't look down the
first time i played it
like it took me because like i noticed
the tummy but i just thought it was like
just an average looking girl you know
yeah there you go
whoa dude that was fantastic
that was really really cool what remains
of
edith finch a few people have um shouted
out
joseph anderson who apparently does
video essays about the game um seems
like a
i don't know joseph i don't know his uh
background or
his general who he is but um a
bunch of people have said he's doing
great work on on this so it might be
worth checking that stuff out
um yeah i uh i've watched a bunch of
joseph's videos he's he's
excellent he's really really good great
brilliant
we interacted very briefly on twitter
where he was like silent 2 isn't that
great
and i was like yes it is i really like
your videos
oh but yeah i've actually never watched
his videos on this i'll have to check
him out
yeah there you go um wow yes
in that in that final stretch we had a
donation from
john habgood of 50 dollars
nice thank you so much john i didn't
want to
say anything while you were in the home
stretch because
that's how this whole thing is yeah
it would have cut the tension a little
bit yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah this is this is a very good
game especially on repeat playthroughs
and this is one of those games where
it's
great to watch other people play it for
the first time
um and so i think you're going to have a
great time if you do play it with
your partner or whoever yeah um
i think i think i could go i think i
could definitely go for that
for you yeah that's that that has been
um
what remains of edith finch with the
wonderful
super eye patch john thank you so much
so much for having me it's it was a
total blast dude honestly
i'd absolutely be up for doing this
again in some form for sure man um
definitely want to have you back again
now that we've done it once i'm sure
it'll be comfortable and easy to do it
again a bunch of times i'd love to get
you on our podcast as well at some point
happily yeah let's do it but yeah if you
if you
are watching this and aren't familiar
with john's work please do check out
super eye patch wolf on youtube i'm
a fan we've got multiple fans there's
the let's fight a boss podcast as well
which is one of my favorite
gaming slash pop culture podcasts please
do check it out
and you get plenty more of of of john
there um
and good i i patch wolf takes there but
otherwise
thank you so much for joining us um we
are going to carry on doing streams for
a little while longer at least a week
and a half um
and the links that are below uh beat
bit.your wife.js hyphen blm for
blacklivesmatterbit.ly4.gs
hyphen covid are remaining active you
can donate
um at any time for those uh efforts and
fundraising efforts so please do
and um we'll see you again tomorrow
tomorrow we're gonna have um
people make games is chris pratt playing
um a game mountain blade two i believe
with dave dewitt from the uk's game oh
cool um and that's going to be a lot of
fun i think they're going to play the
baby mode where you can play their game
as a baby which is wild
um but yeah that should be fun so yeah
we'll see you
neil truckman as a tester no that can't
be the same person sorry
you never know maybe it is yeah i guess
so
but yeah thank you everyone for watching
um thanks so much guys this this is a
blast and thanks for having me tomorrow
like this was so much fun seriously
anytime
anytime but yeah i think if if eric tay
our voice of god is there we're gonna
fade out now um i did tell him it might
take a little longer but um
uh because we were reaching the end of
the game but hopefully he's there tay
take us away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you